let's go speed run time roll the cameras
we're white
now we're going to go d4 we played d4
earlier i want to bore you guys to death
with some positional stuff
so let's play some d4 openings in the
next couple of games with white
[Music]
okay so here we can play a bunch of
different things we can play a london
system we can play trumpowski
but let's play the main line let's play
c4
okay so he plays g6 that's either the
king's indian or the grunfeld we go
knight c3 of course okay king's indian
and we are playing against the king's
indian okay so he castles now the
interesting thing about this move
if you've watched a bunch of kings
indian game you'll know that d6 is
generally the move
but castles is fine
and the movie five which aims to punish
black is bad
and it's known to be bad ever since
bobby fischer won a very famous game in
the in that line in in the 60s so we
want to play this exactly as
we would play a normal king's indian and
the line that i recommend to almost
everybody
um
to almost everybody
in this rating range 1700 is the
same-ish i think the same-ish
is the easiest line to understand the
ideas are very clear
and it's the most dangerous line against
somebody who's not very well-versed
in king's indian theory black can get
checkmated
really really easily so we're going to
play the move f3
okay so d6 so the point of f3 is twofold
threefold were
obviously reinforcing the e4 pawn we are
preparing at a later point the pawn
storm
involving g4 and we are in the same vein
preventing the knight from coming to g4
which is important because we now
develop our bishop to e3
e5
so
the ideal scenario in the same ish goes
as follows we want to close down the
center
we want to go queen d2 and castle long
and then we want to checkmate him
sicilian style on the king's side and go
bishop h6h4h5hg
and mate him so
black has to stop us from doing these
things in that order and that's not as
easy as it seems
so the movie 5 is the old school main
line that's the old-fashioned main line
uh and what should we do here how should
we continue
yeah so we should go d5 closing down the
center that's the first
uh first step and c6 is
indeed the correct the correct move
okay so now we
aim to accomplish the second step of our
mission which is to castle one we need
to tuck our king away
queen to d2
cd will play cd okay bishop d7 is very
awkward
i'm not sure i understand
what he's trying to do with that move it
deprives the knight of its natural
developing square
okay so
obviously now we're going to castle and
complete our
uh the sort of second stage of our plane
it goes b5
so i think his heart is in the right
place here he's trying to attack on the
queen side but the wheels are going to
come off pretty quickly
so we can play cb that's pretty much
fine but i think there's an even better
version of this we can do what else
how else can we
do this essentially
yeah we can play dc
that exposes a very weak pawn on d6 and
we're going to end up taking b5
uh in a very very good version so
aren't we opening up the center and i
just said we should keep it closed well
the circumstances have changed he's
given us a pawn
and the great thing about the same-ish
is that it's a very structurally healthy
opening so it's not like by opening the
center you're exposing yourself somehow
right we're perfectly well developed our
center is under is in very good hands
what should we take the pawn with
and this is a pretty tricky question
because
i talked about this a lot yesterday the
concept that a lot of people want to
make moves that carry threats so i think
a lot of you will be tempted to take
with the pawn but
you should take with a knight
and the reason why is the taking with
the pawn first of all opens up the c
file and only he can benefit from that
and in addition
he will be able to play the move knight
to d4 and i'll talk a little bit about
that after the game this is definitely
the best move
and finally yeah we're attacking d6 with
three different pieces the rook the
queen and the knight
a5
he continues trying to attack but he's
grasping at straws here there's really
nothing to attack
now what should we do
well time to reap the reap the harvest
obviously we should take this pawn
there's no need not to and we should
take with the queen let's take it with
the queen swooping in really paralyzing
him with our two pieces
and
if he moves the bishop then we'll get a
chance to trade queens which is great
for us because we're now up two pawns
this is just
knight takes d6 was also very much
possible i don't think it really matters
it's you both moves seem perfectly good
and this is just horrific for black
knight b4 is a good move that's a that's
a good try
so he's
i mean he's attacking the a2 pawn and
there's no need to give that pawn away
so what should we do what's the simplest
move
yeah just a3 chase the knight away we
could also go king to b1 that's a
good prophylactic move but a3 comes with
tempo so i like it a little bit more our
king is
perfectly safe on c1 it's not like he's
going to do anything with it
and now
um
after he moves the knight
bishop g5 is coming yeah so
what we're noticing here is that the
bishop on d7 is defended by queen and
it's defended by the knight you've got a
very convenient move that
pins the knight and threatens to win the
bishop by taking the knight
and the only way he can defend against
that is by moving his bishop which
allows and turn the queen trade
knight c6
and bishop g5 that seems very reasonable
against another gm i would probably
develop my knight and bring it over to
c3 just to beef up the security on the
king's side but here we can go in for
the kill i don't really mind
i hope this is making sense this is this
should be pretty straightforward to
everybody rook c8 and what do we do now
he's not effectively doing anything
against our threat now why did we play
bishop g5 let's remember ah it was to
take on f6
and then
the bishop on d7 is
toast boom
now he's going to play queen b6 here
after which it's going to be very
important to be cautious for a couple of
moves because
remember we're still quite undeveloped i
mean our whole king side is undeveloped
so
you know it's like we won a lottery
ticket
but we're you know in a war zone and we
need to escape the war zone and then we
can cash our lottery ticket in and we
can live happily ever after so we just
need to survive for a couple of moves
and this is a
very dangerous period for a lot of
players this is where a lot of players
go wrong
so we need to identify what the sources
of danger are what are the immediate
problems what are the threats what is
black's actual threat here
yeah so rook d8
and we should also
be aware of the possibility of bishop g5
check which could disattach the king
from the rook so rook d8 would actually
then be a devastating pin
so we can't cover the d8 square
but um
what can we do
how can we take the sting out of
preferably both of these moves we can
play a very simple move
okay bishop e2
is okay it defends the rook but i would
still be very concerned about rook fda
we'd have to bring our queen to the side
and i really want our queen to be
participating in the defense so what you
guys a lot of you are proposing moves
like queen g4 which is not bad but again
you don't have the luxury of abandoning
your king you have to keep your king
your queen close to your chest so queen
to d2 is going to be the best move
and i'll talk about knight t6 knight t6
rook he would move the other rook to d8
i think
or even rook fda would still be very
strong
so what's the logic here
a lot of you are are i think
instinctively avoiding this move because
recov d8 comes with tempo it attacks the
queen but remember what i said yesterday
the same tip comes in handy again and
again you shouldn't be afraid of a move
only because it creates a threat to one
of your heavy pieces queen or king
this move is no longer dangerous because
our queen has a million different
squares from where it will defend the
rook you can go queen c2 we can go queen
e1
um i'm trying to choose between those
moves i like queen c2
uh because you really just
you know
stay together with your king queen c2
knight d6 would be very dangerous it
would walk into a pin
so if he goes knight d4 we just take his
knight i think it's possible that he
does it
we just take his knight
and the pawn on c4 is perfectly well
defended yeah he does it
okay now
one final move after which we fully
consolidate we're ready to develop what
we certainly don't want to allow him to
do
is to open up this bishop with d3 that
would be a nasty little pawn sacrifice
and so we should take this opportunity
to play bishop d3
and we can breathe easy we're good our
king is relatively safe
we're gonna get our night out and we're
just gonna convert our extra piece
okay so that took like four moves
but we had to be super accurate in those
four moves
check
king b1 is a move we wanted to play
anyway so the check is no longer
dangerous
he can try to alakine gun me but
this pawn on b2 we're going to find the
way to defend it it's not going to be an
issue
one of the
ways that we can yeah that's what he's
trying to do now before we do anything
let's complete our development let's
let's bring our night out so that we
have
access to all of our pieces
bishop e3
that's a good move he's playing well
okay so
how do we go about converting
the the advantage uh the extra piece
well um
first of all i would address
the potential issue of him tripling on
the b-file and i would ask myself
what we can do about that
and one thing that we can do about that
is make sure that we have the capacity
if necessary but only if necessary to
protect the b2 pawn
what reshuffling of our pieces can we
yeah king a1 king a1 is a great
prophylactic move so that if necessary
we can bring our rook over to b1
and our king is as safe as it gets here
king a2 would be a little bit less
accurate because the queen could later
come into b3 with check
which
may become important at some later point
if we like abandon c2 for whatever
reason you always got to take care of
those eventualities
damn girl
nice
that's that is the ultimate we we might
play king a2 if we ever need to defend
the a3 fun and now as many of you
suggested let's not forget that this is
the same ish what do we do in the same
ish let's start attacking nothing
happened
to the prospect of us
orchestrating a kingside attack
so we're not afraid of rook b8 anywhere
we can just go h5 we can rip open the h
file
and now we go rook b1 now rook takes b2
maybe some of you are a little bit
worried about this move but i've
calculated it rook takes b2 rook takes
b2 queen takes a3 check is just a paper
tiger we go rook a2 and the game is over
he doesn't have enough fuel for the fire
rook b3 is a really nice move though
and now the necessity has arisen
uh for us to bring our king up to a2
so
you know the
circumstances change and he goes a4 this
guy is really good
but he has no threats here so let's take
this guy is definitely tremendously good
okay now
we want to lock this bishop up on e3 so
let's play the move f4
and our idea is to go e5
and already i'm
eyeing a bishop sacrifice on g6 that
might just rip open his king i hope that
makes sense
i just don't see any way for him to if
he had one more piece if he had a bishop
on d6 for example but we don't let his
bishop get out then he would threaten a
sacrifice on a3 with mate
as it stands i'm not scared because i've
literally verified that he has zero
ideas on the queen side he's run out of
firepower
the position looks intimidating but
there's nothing concretely
and
we've reached a level where you have to
think very concretely in most positions
you can't just say ah this looks scary
otherwise you're just not going to be
able to properly
test your opponent and call call their
bluff
queen c7
okay just making sure this doesn't pose
any threats it doesn't so how should we
follow up i just mentioned this move but
who wants to remind me of
the the best continuation e5 for sure
and now we're almost definitely
threatening a sack on g6 that's going to
be totally devastating
we can also follow follow through with
f5 yeah he defends that's nice
but now we can recruit this bishop
and
we have several ways i think to win this
game
now the simplest is just to play f5 i
think the simplest is just to play f5
and use the pawns as battering rams we
want to get rid of this jeep on so that
this bishop queen battery
would uh come into full effect
there were many ways to win the game
bishop e4 was also possible yeah that
was my second idea bishop before and
then walk the bishop over to d5
and then some sort of sack on h7 might
decide the game but i decided not to be
adventurous
we'll win this in a more conventional
way
okay so he takes that doesn't do
anything it only helps us by opening the
g file
so let's just take on g6
okay
so again it doesn't matter at this point
how you decide to win
there are a million ways
the simplest and oftentimes in such
positions you don't want to reinvent the
wheel particularly when you've got a
minute and a half left or something like
that
this is not alcohol that's t even
simpler than bishop e4 just take the
pawn take the pawn
open up the entire
um
area of the king side and and then you
can swoop in with queen f5 or or give a
check on f7 or h7 and something's going
to lead to mate
one other idea is then to drop the
bishop back to e4 move it away to d5 and
that also opens up the diagonal for the
queen
the king is wide open
queen back
okay so again just verifying
that this is not a threat takes takes
and let's go with
our initial idea let's drop the bishop
back to e4 reroute it to d5 and that's
going to be all she wrote
yeah this guy was underrated i mean he
was certainly a very tough opponent
bit queen d7 check
and time for the king hunt to begin
time for the king hunt to be and it's
going to end very very quickly
so in such positions my one piece of
advice is not to rush to give the first
check that you see
and i know that the first check a lot of
you might see is a rook f1 check
but when you when you're hunting the
king you got to be very very careful
that you don't let the king escape and
the f you've got to chart
where the esk you've got to build the
map
how could the king hypothetically escape
what is the pathway and then you could
tailor your sequence to prevent the king
from reaching that pathway
so the pathway here is e8 d8 c7 if the
king reaches c7 we're in a little bit of
trouble
so first we need to prevent the king
from coming to e8 well is there a way to
do that there is you just give a check
on h8 the king has to go up to e7 but
now all of the squares are covered
bishop covers e6 pawn covers d6 rook
covers the eighth rank all we need is
one more check and that's going to be
made is there a mate here
there is
checkmate all right
there we go
and that wins the game
i didn't mean to make it seem like it's
close i i saw the maid when we were
giving the check
all right that was a nice game
so f3 yeah now the the fischer game went
e5 98 f4
and bobby basically
crushed up white's pawn chain with d6
and c5
and this is just no good for white so
don't go e5
don't go e5 here i mean you can and if
black doesn't know how to punish it then
it turns out to be really good
but
if you want to play it properly you
should play the same way you would
against d6
okay
so d6 this is all good e5 is fine d5 c6
yeah let's leah fisher
queen d2
so bishop d7 is the first mistake
um
the the way to play this line is to play
a6 and basically prepare b5
so white castles i've had a couple games
in this line with black i used to play
this line with black you develop your
knight you go b5 you go queen a5 but
white is better here i mean if white
plays it properly you want to throw in
king b1 just just for
just for kicks and then you want to
basically start attacking h4 g4 bishop
h6 all that stuff
so what's up man
so this is
i would say not the best line for black
but it's pretty reputable and it's not
easy to refute
okay so bishop d7
castles uh and b5 is well intentioned
but just wrong for tactical read just
doesn't work
so dc
uh cuts the whole
you know mechanism
down
yeah e5 is e5 definitely is legitimate
it's just not the best line it's not bad
but it's i think white is better there
can i take c6
so
yeah so basically the game is already
over after knight takes b5
we just take another pawn
chase the knight away and then we win
the night i mean this just was boom boom
boom and the game was over
um
okay
now um
that was basically it i mean he had
some ways of saving maybe a6 here and
then bishop e6 something like this to
climb out of the pin
was better but by and large this was
just already over before it began
all right
okay guys i'm gonna call it a day
so thanks guys uh take care everybody
and and i'll see you guys soon uh thanks
again for the support i'll see you guys
tomorrow bye
[Music]
you